IAN NI-LEWIS: Hello, everyone.
My name is Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: And I'm
Reto Meier.
And on today's "App Clinic,"
we'll be looking at apps
people while they're
traveling.
IAN NI-LEWIS: [COUGHS]
That's an excellent idea.
And I just swallowed coffee
down my lungs.
Why don't you take
the next line.
RETO MEIER: That is the
wrong place to be
drinking your coffee.
Gone are the days of badly
folded maps, guidebooks, and
laminated holiday itineraries.
Today you can keep everything
you need in the
palm of your hand.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
No longer will you look like a
bumbling tourist standing on
the corner of Oxford Street and
Charing Cross Road with
your London street map
unfolded before you,
fruitlessly trying to figure
out which direction is--
you know, I never
even do that.
RETO MEIER: No?
What's your plan?
IAN NI-LEWIS: My plan is,
I'm always looking
at the curb in London.
Because it tells me which way
the traffic is flowing.
RETO MEIER: That is very true.
Keeping your eye on the road
is probably wise for an
American in London if
you don't want to be
murdered by a black cab.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In any case,
let's face it.
When you're in a foreign city,
foreign country, there's a lot
to keep in your mind.
And I don't think my mind
is big enough to
encompass it all.
RETO MEIER: Well, you want to
be able to use your mind for
things like appreciating the
sights and sounds of the new
city that you're visiting, not
trying to remember exactly
where you need to be and how
you're going to get there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And you certainly
do not want to be
unfolding a paper map because
that's just like a sign that
says "mug me."
RETO MEIER: Yeah, please
steal my stuff.
I have stuff.
I probably have three weeks'
worth of money in my pocket.
Please, rob me.
And that is not the message you
want to be sending out.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's funny,
because you do get different
reactions in every city.
For instance, in London, I think
they just try and sell
you a three-card Monte.
In New York, they kill you.
In Beijing, they want to
take you to tea, and
then you pay for it.
And in Shanghai, they want to
introduce you to your sister--
their sister.
RETO MEIER: Well, introducing
them to my sister would be
interesting.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Eh, that too.
RETO MEIER: Particularly as
I don't have a sister.
Anyway, so today we're going
to be looking at four apps
that the viewers have nominated
as must-have travel
assistance apps.
So we're going to be looking
at social venue discovery
classic Foursquare--
IAN NI-LEWIS: The ultimate
in travel management--
TripIt.
RETO MEIER: --and one-click
location-sharing widget, Share
Where location widget.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
We'll be taking a closer look
at each of these apps and
using them as a kicking off
point to explore the
technologies and the best
practices that you need in
order to create a must-have
travel app.
RETO MEIER: All that
and more on--
IAN NI-LEWIS: "The
App Clinic."
RETO MEIER: So a travel
assistant is a pretty broad
category, and that's being
reflected in the three apps
that we'll be looking
at today.
IAN NI-LEWIS: As part of the
Developer Relations team at
Google, travel is a big part of
our job-- or it used to be
before we got this boss video
studio, the video studio that
puts that thing in back of us.
Hey!
So this is a category that we
are intimately familiar with.
I've been traveling
for work for what?
10 years now, and it
can be a nightmare.
RETO MEIER: It's also one of
the more popular groups of
apps in Google Play.
And the popular apps in this
category tend to have very
loyal and passionate uses.
Take, for example, Foursquare.
So let's have a look.
Boy, look at that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Beautiful.
Now this isn't a travel app per
se, but it's definitely
useful as a travel app.
I think you had some insights
into that recently.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Let's see.
We want to put that in front.
In fact, yeah.
I remember how this was
supposed to work now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes, indeed.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
So when I was growing up in
Australia, Foursquare was the
name of an independent group of
supermarkets whose TV ads
implored me to come in
for a square deal.
So every time I look at this
app, I hear the jingle playing
in my head.
Leaving that aside, I'm a big
fan of Foursquare, both for
the service and the features
that they offer as well as
their passion for creating a
really great user experience,
which is a really
important thing.
We can see that over the course
of the years, the
Foursquare app has really
progressed.
As each version of Android
has come out, they've
refreshed the UI.
They've taken advantage of some
of our best practices.
So this is an app that I'm
a really big fan of.
Now, strictly speaking, you
don't need to be traveling for
Foursquare to be useful.
In a lot of ways, it's most
useful when you're close to
home, doing your
daily routine.
I know a lot of people whose
coffee shop loyalty is based
around fierce competition to
maintain their status as mayor
of Pete's Coffee Shop on the
corner of El Camino and San
Antonio roads.
Now, a big part of Foursquare's
success is also
around the social elements of
its use, as indicated by this
screenshot.
It's a way to share where you
are, let you know where your
friends are hanging out, and
all those sorts of things.
But for today, we're going to
be focusing on its use while
you're on the road.
And that's where I found it
to be the most compelling.
When I'm away from home on a
trip, there's really no chance
I'm going to become the mayor
of anything except for maybe
the hotel that I'm saying at.
So the app's primary use case
switches is from consistent
use of the same venues to
discovery and exploration.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, this is the
part that I really wanted to
hear about because I have
avoided Foursquare forever.
First, because it was a hipster
app, and second,
because I just couldn't see
the use in being a mayor.
I'm the kind of person who's
so ultra-competitive that I
avoid competition just so
I don't have to lose.
RETO MEIER: That's
pretty hard core.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
RETO MEIER: I like it.
So when I lived in London, I'd
visit the mother ship here at
Google every three
months or so.
And as soon as I landed in
SFO and checked in to the
terminal, it was game on--
coffee shops, hotels,
restaurants, hot dog stands,
pretty much anything.
I used to travel with--
well, I think only once or twice
with Nick and Richard.
And those guys would be on the
Cal train checking into each
Cal train stop as they
went past it.
So as far as competition
goes, those guys
are pretty hard core.
So the thrill of rocketing
up the leaderboard is a
short-term gain, although what
really makes this app a travel
assistance powerhouse is its
discoverability features.
So back in--
I can't even remember
when it was--
2009, 2010, whenever the Nexus
One came out I went on a
10-day European road show where
we hit something like
nine cities in 10 days, stayed
in each one just long enough
to get a good night's sleep,
hand out a couple Nexus Ones,
and grab a meal.
So suddenly--
IAN NI-LEWIS: We don't do that
anymore, by the way.
We do not hand out
phones anymore.
RETO MEIER: Which is sad.
That was a lot of fun.
It was an easy way to make
friends in foreign cities.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right?
It's like being those GIs in
World War II with their
chocolate and cigarettes.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
They loved me.
Everywhere I went,
they loved me.
I'm sure it had nothing to
do with the giveaways.
So suddenly, having an app that
tells you where you can
get a good meal and rewards you
with points for doing so
really becomes very appealing.
So I'm going to go into more
detail as to how the social
discovery service on
Foursquare works a
little later on.
But first, let's take
a look at TripIt.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
Oh wow.
It's totally covered up.
OK.
Oh, right.
We're supposed to
do it this way.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, clever, huh?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love TripIt.
By the way, I should
mention that Reto
fracking loves TripIt.
RETO MEIER: I do.
I love it a lot.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But I don't
fracking love it, because it's
not 2008 anymore.
RETO MEIER: Burn!
IAN NI-LEWIS: When I started
going on business trips, I
didn't even have a cell phone,
much less a smartphone.
I had to manually create my
own version of TripIt with
printouts of bookings, and
receipts, and flight
itineraries, and maps
to my apartment,
and maps to the train.
And I kept doing
this for years.
When I worked for Microsoft, I
tried to do it with a Windows
mobile phone.
That didn't work out so well.
Nothing against--
well, OK.
Anyway, later on, I switched to
an iPhone, and then when I
came here, I switched
to an Android phone.
But honestly, the experience
was still unsatisfying.
And the most important problem
was that my itineraries would
be in my email.
And I'd have to make sure, A,
that it was synced to the
right folder in my email, and
B, that it synced and remain
synced and didn't get tossed out
by the time I needed it.
So I would frequently find
myself in line for, let's say,
a rental car, frantically
charging my phone off of my
laptop battery pack, just so I
could bring up an email that
told me where and when
I was supposed to be
at a certain place.
At this point, though, I don't
have to do any of that.
With TripIt, I can just set it
up to go through my email and
find all of the travel-related
stuff, although it turns out
that the security guys at
Google don't like that.
So I had to stop that.
But fortunately, what you can
do is set up an email
forwarding rule.
Just take everything that you
get from Expedia or Carlson
Wagonlit or the other places
that we use to book travel and
just forward it on to TripIt.
And TripIt will actually
figure out
what the email means.
It'll pull out all of the
details about you hotel and
about your flights.
And then it will store that
and send you reminders
whenever you need them.
So by the time I'm sitting in
the taxi to go to the airport,
I've got my entire trip right
in front of me-- hotels,
weather, cars, directions, even
information about what
friends of mine that use TripIt
are going to be in the
same place at the same time.
But for me, the most exciting
part about TripIt is just the
way it seems to work
like magic.
Everything just appears.
It comes up when it should.
It lets me know what time
I need to be where.
It figures out where I am
and where I need to be.
And it works offline without
having to connect up to an
internet, which is really,
really important as you're
traveling, because a lot of
times, internet access is
either unavailable or incredibly
expensive.
It also does some clever
things with intents.
And Reto's going to be going
over that a little bit later.
But before we do that, it's time
to take a quick look at--
RETO MEIER: We're going
to take a look
at Share Where widget.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice handoff.
That was beautiful.
RETO MEIER: I thought
it was really clean.
So I'm going to start to move
over to this side, because I
know that we're going
to be in frame.
Now, I just want to take a
moment to comment on the
Google Play landing page for
Share Where location widget.
I really love the icon here.
It's got that distinctive shape
that provides really
strong branding and even a hint
as to what the app does
without resorting to that square
with rounded corners
that you see so much.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
They have a great icon, and it
doesn't have a background.
Love it.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
It's also great to see that
they've got a feature graphic.
But here I think they could
take another pass at this.
The feature graphics are
really used in a lot of
different places, including on
the phone, not always at this
massive size and resolution
that you can see here.
So a graphic like this that
includes a lot of text is
going to be pretty illegible
when it gets shrunk down into
the smaller sizes.
So I'd suggest it you rely on
the description field, which
is just below it, to detail the
functionality of the app,
and really make the
feature graphic
a little more stylized.
In the same that you've got this
great logo icon, make it
more like that so that you're
giving an idea of the app
rather than trying to explain
everything within a small
feature graphic.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know
what this feature
graphic says to me?
RETO MEIER: What does it say?
IAN NI-LEWIS: It says, they
hired a great designer, and he
made a great icon.
And then the CEO put together
the feature graphic.
RETO MEIER: We've got
everything we need.
We don't need to pay another
guy a couple of grand to
create the feature graphic.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
I've got Photoshop.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So yeah, maybe make it look
like a designer did the
feature graphic as well.
I think that's really going
to help you out.
It just gives you that much
more professional feel.
And now if we actually look at
the app itself, in terms of
functionality, this is
a much simpler--
maybe you would even say tighter
focus than either of
the other apps we're
looking at today.
So the idea here is a
pretty simple one.
It lets you create a home screen
widget or a number of
home screen widgets which will
send preset messages to one or
more recipients.
And those messages can go out
via SMS, email, or actually
using any app that you
like using intents.
It's a simple concept, and one
which I actually considered
writing a while back, an app I
called one-click SMS, which
had a very similar idea.
So if I just wanted to always
tell my wife I'm on my way
home when I was on my way home
without having to try and do
all the swipey stuff,
just press a button.
And that's exactly what
this app does.
So I love the idea of having a
one-touch emergency widget on
my home screen to let friends
and family know that I've
survived the inevitable
San Francisco
earthquake, or that I'm--
I'll try that again.
And that I'm OK.
Or that I'm not OK and having
my location embedded within
that message so that they know
where in the rubble to dig
through I think would be really
useful, as well as
things like I've arrived safely,
my flight's just
landed, I'm on my way home, any
of those sorts of things.
So being able to do all of that
really quickly without
having to scroll through
contacts lists or try and type
in a keyboard while I'm walking,
half-asleep with jet
lag, is really a plus.
There's some UI work
that could be done
to improve the UX.
And I'll go into a little bit
more detail on that later.
But they've done some great work
in terms of keeping the
functionality simple and using
intents to make the app even
powerful without having
to do much extra work.
So the best thing that they've
done is keep it simple in an
app that does one thing, and
it does it very well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Love it.
So each of these apps offers
some valuable features to help
you when you're traveling.
Taking a step back, let's take
a look at the key features
we're looking for in a pure
Android travel assistance app.
RETO MEIER: OK, so the feature
set of each of these apps are
kind of orthogonal.
They're all really useful
for travelers.
But there's very
little overlap.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
So that's handy, because it
helps focus on how they're
achieving some of that magical
feature set rather than
debating the relative merits
of each feature.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So each of these apps needs to
work when I'm away from home,
because they're travel apps.
That's whole point.
And so that means that I'm
likely to be charging my phone
less often.
So battery life and battery
consumption
becomes really important.
Data transfer is likely
to be slower.
It's probably going
to be roaming.
So it's probably going
to be expensive.
So back home, I may not care.
Suddenly, I'm in Italy.
I'm paying a lot more for
my roaming costs.
So I care about that
data transfer.
And frankly, I'm probably going
to be turning it on and
off, depending on when
I need stuff.
IAN NI-LEWIS: At the same time,
a lot of times when
you're traveling, you will get
great data every now and then,
like when you've got Wi-Fi.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So in Italy, for
instance, they have Wi-Fi on
the trains.
If you can hook up to that--
RETO MEIER: No, no-- they have
"wiffy" on the trains.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, I'm sorry.
RETO MEIER: In Italy,
it's all "wiffy."
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
(AUSTRALIAN ACCENT) Shrimp
on the barbie.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, the point
is that you're not just
having nonexistent data or
expensive data, you're having
very intermittent data.
So when you do have Wi-Fi, or
"wiffy," or "wah-foe," or
whatever it is, you probably
want to take the most
advantage of that.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And of course, location
is key.
It's particularly important
because you want to
know where you are.
But this has to balanced around
the fact that you don't
want to be draining the battery
getting those location
updates all the time.
So it's really a balancing act
of wanting to have fresh data,
having constant data, working
offline, accurate location,
without draining the battery
when, chances are, you're
going to have your phone.
You're going to be using it a
lot, but you're only going to
be charging it at the
end of every day.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: So the final result
really does emphasize
the efficiency of apps
serving this market.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So at last year's
I/O, Reto spent a bunch
of time talking about how to
ensure your app is always
fresh, which is extremely
important for apps.
Is that an Android
using deodorant?
RETO MEIER: It is, to
maintain freshness.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Silly person.
Androids don't smell.
RETO MEIER: I'm just going to
put that in front so everyone
can see the link to the
presentation as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, so it was all
about freshness, not just
about Androids using deodorant,
but also--
this is really important
for apps like
Foursquare and TripIt.
In these sorts of situations,
latency is your enemy,
particularly if you're late for
a train, or you're just
tired after a long day of
sightseeing, and you just want
to find somewhere to eat.
What you don't want to do is
spend a lot of time waiting
for your phone to refresh, to
find a connection, to download
information.
You just want to have everything
at your fingertips
so that you can glance at it and
keep running, basically.
So Let's take a look
at Foursquare in
a little more detail.
All right, so let me bring
up the giant phone.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Giant
fake phone, wooo!
RETO MEIER: Perfect.
So you can see that Foursquare
has done a fantastic job on
pretty much everything.
They've created something that's
really engaging, really
interesting, really
great to look at.
They've got a modern-looking
UI.
You can look at it straightaway,
and you can see
that it feels like a modern
Android phone.
It's all using Holo theming,
all of that good stuff.
And what's really useful here
is that what Ian is
experimenting with here is the
local search feature, which we
were discussing beforehand.
And that's kind of
the key here.
So you can see as we
go through here,
it's got the map.
It's showing where
your friends are.
So if you're traveling in a
group, which is something we
used to do a lot of for things
like Google Developer Days and
DevFests, you can see where
other people that you're
traveling with are at.
Where's everyone going out for
a drink after the conference
is finished?
You can track them all down.
You can find places that other
people have rated, perhaps on
previous trips.
So it's really a way for you to
be able to get some idea of
confidence as to where
should I go?
I just want to grab a meal.
I'm in a place that I'm
not familiar with.
What's a good place?
Is there anywhere where it's
recommending in the nearby
neighborhood that you would
agree or disagree with?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, absolutely,
Cafe Blaze.
RETO MEIER: Blaze is great.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Excellent cafe.
RETO MEIER: So that's a good
choice that they've selected
there, actually.
And you can go through, and this
sort of consistent, clean
UI is pervasive throughout
the entire app.
It shows you the information
that you want--
address, details, who's checked
in, photos, all of
that sort of information, and
does it in a really clean,
natural way.
Again, what I really like about
this is the simplicity.
It keeps everything
really simple.
It shows you the information
that you need without making
an overly complicated UI.
So it really is something that's
easy to use and quite
addictive, I think.
You don't have this mountain
of information.
I think that's a challenge for
a lot of apps like this is
that there are a lot
of venues around.
So there's this tendency to just
drop 1,000 pins on the
screen at any given time.
And that's not actually
really useful.
What you want to know is,
where do I want to go?
And this is somewhere where
choice can be a problem.
If I'm standing on Castro
Street, I know there's a bunch
of restaurants around.
I want to know which one I
should go to based on the
things that I like, that my
friends have checked in to,
and those sorts of things.
And that's something which
I think they do a
really good job of.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
And just as a side note, you can
see that the design here
is really beautiful.
And they've done some
of the things that
we've talked about--
putting your media front and
center, making sure that you
make good use of space.
Every time something is blank,
it's for a reason, but mostly,
just bringing up these
beautiful, beautiful pictures.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean, that's what
this is all about.
I mean, what Foursquare has ,
which a lot of other apps
which are offering similar
services don't, is a huge
community of people which
are contributing to the
information here.
So we have lots of pictures
contributed by users which you
can trust, because it's not the
picture that the owner has
taken on the day where he's
cleared out everyone and given
everything a spic-and-span
clean.
It's pictures which people have
taken while they've been
hanging out there.
So they've done a
really good job.
So what I want to talk about a
little bit is use this as an
excuse to talk a little bit
about how Foursquare have done
the job that they have done.
It's simple enough to get
location updates for Android.
But what Foursquare have done a
really good job of is making
sure that location updates are
as low latency as possible.
So there's a few tricks you
can use to maintain your
location freshness without
draining the battery
completely.
So you can significantly
reduce the battery--
sorry, you can significantly
reduce the latency for getting
your first location fix by
retrieving the last known
location from the location
manager each
time the app is resumed.
So if you have a look at
this code snippet--
I'll just pop that in front as
well so you can perhaps read
that a little bit more easily.
So in this snippet, we're going
to iterate through each
location provider on the device,
including those that
aren't currently available.
And we're going to seek out
the most timely and most
accurate last known location.
So if there's one or more
locations available from
within the allowed time frame,
then we can return the one
which has the most
accurate result.
And if there isn't,
then we return
the most recent results.
Though if we're just doing
that-- the most recent result,
but it's kind of beyond
our latency window--
it's pretty good practice to
request a single location
update from every available
provider to try and get a more
recent result.
At this point, it doesn't even
matter which is the more
accurate result.
You just want to get something
that's a little more timely so
that you get something
which is in the
vaguely correct location.
And then obviously, you can
continue to do your location
updates to try and get something
even more useful.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So one thing that
I've always wanted to ask
you, Reto, about location,
because I know you're kind of
the location guy.
RETO MEIER: Sure.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So I remember
when I first started
traveling, and this was way back
in the Dark Ages when we
didn't have offline maps and
we didn't have really good
location providers.
And I found out an app called
Maverick that was mostly for
geocaching.
And so they made it work
in the wilderness.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And it turned
out that for me, anyway,
coming from the US, London
was the wilderness.
RETO MEIER: Effectively.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So what it did was
it allowed me to download
a bunch of map tiles,
which may or may not
actually been legal.
RETO MEIER: It downloaded
them regardless.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
And then it would find GPS, but
it also kept track of my
location through
dead reckoning.
Do any of the phones we have
now do that automatically?
Is that part of the
location provider?
RETO MEIER: Not that
I'm aware of, no.
I think the location providers
that we're using at the moment
are fairly simplistic
in that it's just
GPS or network location--
what do we call it?
NLP, Network Location
Provider.
So using cell ID and Wi-Fi
rather than momentum and dead
reckoning and those sorts of
things, although I think
that's something which the
industry is heading towards.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: So it would be
fantastic to see more and more
of those sorts of features
become part of the location
providers available.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wouldn't
that be great?
Now, what implications does that
have for power, though?
RETO MEIER: Well, I guess that's
kind of the question.
And that's one of the important
reasons why within
Android, you shouldn't be
specifying a particular
location provider.
So at the moment, it's just
assumed that GPS is going to
drain your battery, and the
network location provider is
going to be relatively
low-power.
But these days, it's actually
becoming a point where a lot
of the GPS chips are becoming
more and more power efficient
and getting built into the
hardware itself so that the
actual location drain is
significantly lower.
By comparison, the network
location providers are using a
lot more features, things like
gyroscopes, things like
momentum, all of those things
which can comparatively
increase its battery drain.
So what it then means is it's
kind of up to the system to
figure out how to balance those
things and provide you
with as accurate a result
as you can without
draining the battery.
And so for us right now, that
means using things like
criteria to specify a location
provider based on the power
drain or the accuracy you need
rather than saying, hey, I
think that this implies that,
so I'm going to use that
particular provider.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So as with many
things Android, you really
don't want to go too low-level
yourself, because you know
that things are going
to get better.
And they're going to get better
in a very unpredictable
way, where on some devices
they're much better in terms
of power, for instance.
And other devices, they haven't
made those changes.
So you're always safest going
with the basic system.
And then if you absolutely
have to tweak things for
specific classes of devices,
maybe you want to do that.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
A good example is if you're
creating a device which lets
you understand how many GPS
satellites you've got in
view-- and we looked at a couple
of these apps a little
while ago, some of
these GPS apps.
Clearly they want the GPS
provider, whether it's
accurate or draining the battery
or whatever, they
don't really care.
That's not the point.
For everything else,
you want to be as
high-level as possible.
And then trust that as the
framework team are able to
make improvements to these APIs,
that suddenly your app
will get better and more
efficient and more accurate
without you actually having
to do anything.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Yeah, I think this
is a good area.
If you're doing a location app,
stay tuned and make sure
you follow not only Android,
but the different chipset
vendors and see what kind of
changes they're making,
because I know there's
a lot of active
research in this area.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I think we've been hearing a lot
about things like passive
background location updates.
And you can see apps like Google
Now, in fact, being
able to give you these really
cool hints about how far
you've walked or suggesting
things based on your location
and those sorts of stuff.
So that's kind of cool.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about how you can do some of
those things in just a minute.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Great.
Let's do that.
RETO MEIER: So generally, I
prefer to use pending intents
rather than location
listeners when I'm
making my location requests.
And that's because it offers the
flexibility of registering
receivers in multiple activities
or services or even
directly in a manifest.
In fact, by doing that, you
can make your app silently
update your location, just like
what we mentioned, and
potentially even update the
list of nearby venues.
So an app like Foursquare can
passively listen for these
location changes, and then in
the background every once in a
while actually pull down
nearby locations.
So when you open the app, you're
not waiting for that
feeling like it's
interminable.
Come on.
Yeah, I was there half
an hour ago.
I'm here now.
Just give me something
more reasonable.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And let's
remember, too, that while
you're doing this, it's very,
very important to persist that
information.
Because you're pending intents
and any listener of this type
is going to be running in the
background, which means that
if the user, let's say, boots up
a game or starts to run out
of battery, you're going to be
on the list to be killed.
And if you're keeping that
information in memory, then
it's just going to go away.
And essentially, you've
just wasted a bunch
of power for nothing.
So make absolutely sure that
that gets persisted out to
either a content provider or
your own file system database
or whatever.
RETO MEIER: Share preferences
can be a good
one for that as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There
you go, exactly.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So now requesting locations
updates, particularly if
you're using something like GPS,
anything which is high
power while your app isn't
in the foreground, is
kind of a bad idea.
It's going to drain
the battery.
It's going to make
people angry.
So what you're going to do
instead is use a passive
location provider to piggyback
your location updates when
other apps are requesting
them.
So again, I'm going to pop
the code in front.
So you can see in this code
snippet, we request location
updates using a passive
provider, this thing in a
broadcast, of pending intent
whenever it receives any of
those changes.
And it includes a receiver
definition as well down at the
bottom, which is what you put
in your manifest, which is
then going to listen for those
broadcast intents in order so
that you can then do something
with them.
So within our receiver
definition, we can choose what
to do when those new locations
coming in, which may be store
the location for later use,
though often, that's going to
be duplicating the work that
you can do just by querying
the get last known location.
Or you can do other things
like pre-fetching nearby
locations when certain
conditions are met.
So you may want to do that much
less frequently than the
updates that you
are receiving.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Now, the door has just opened,
and Billy is sticking is head
in, so there's something
wrong with the show.
What's wrong, Billy?
No?
BILLY: All good.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh.
RETO MEIER: Outstanding.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Beautiful.
RETO MEIER: He's just
making sure we're
actually doing work.
We're not just sitting
in here drinking.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
RETO MEIER: I respect his
confidence in us.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: Let's move on.
That's an entirely blank screen,
very disconcerting.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Mike Winton,
don't ever stick
your head in again.
You screwed up everything.
RETO MEIER: So this technique
of pre-fetching
can be really powerful.
But it's also inherently risky,
as you're introducing
battery and bandwidth cost by
downloading data that may
never actually be necessary.
So if you're looking at a travel
assistance app, that
can be kind of touch and go.
And that's something which
I think Foursquare are
really aware of.
And this is an app, where again,
that balance between
being an app that you use a lot
at home and an app that's
really useful when you're away
becomes an interesting balance
of how do you maintain that
freshness without draining the
battery and becoming something
which people don't want to
have running when they're
overseas.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, I think this
actually starts to get
into the secret sauce of what
makes an app truly amazing and
what it means--
for instance, we've talked
about this with the video
apps, where everybody and their
brother uses some form
of media player on any platform,
Flash player on the
web, for instance.
But where the secret sauce comes
in is how do you make
something start really fast and
play at a good bandwidth
and switch bandwidth easily.
And in location apps, it's
really, how do you know when a
person's going to
try and use it?
If you look at what we've done
with Google Now, it really
tries to predict based on your
past behavior, what you're
going to need at a
particular point.
And I think that when you look
at Foursquare, you're seeing
some of the smarts and some
of those intelligences.
You could probably even go
further and make it into
something where you kind
of know when the
app's going to be needed.
Because you can see where the
user is, and even how fast
they're going and what time of
day it is, and predict what
kind of information they're
going to need.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So another useful best practice
is monitoring the
state of your providers.
So this is kind of important.
When you make a location update
request, even when
you're using criteria, the
location manager is just going
to choose one of those providers
whose updates it's
going to monitor.
So whatever provider happens to
be active, whether the user
has GPS ticked or the network
location provided ticked, it's
going to try make
a determination
based on what's available.
But that can change
in real time.
So again, I'm going to
stick this code--
yeah, I'm going to stick
this in front.
Then I can move around
a little bit more.
So this snippet is monitoring
two conditions.
It's checking to find out the
location provider that we're
using to see if it's
being deactivated.
So a user can turn
these on and off.
So it's checking to make sure
that, OK, we've decided to use
GPS, and the user goes
and turns off GPS.
We're going to be able to then
find another provider.
And likewise, we're going to
check to see if there is
another provider that
becomes available.
So maybe we would have used GPS,
but it was disabled, and
then it gets turned on.
We want to switch without the
user having to exit the app
and come back in or manually
do something that way.
It should all happen
dynamically.
In either case, we're just going
to re-run the process
used to determine which provider
that is currently
available is best for
our current needs.
And this technique ensures
that we can continue to
receive location updates without
interruption even if
the user is totaling
GPS and network
location provider details.
That's interesting.
I'm sure that there was
a picture behind us.
Nonetheless, you can find all of
these tips in great detail
in the "Deep Dive into Location"
blog post that is
actually on the next page.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I am so sorry.
I fixed almost all of those
typography errors.
And this one, I guess
I didn't see it.
RETO MEIER: That's OK, but
nonetheless, so this is a blog
post I wrote mid-last
year, I think.
I even created a sample project
that includes the
basic Foursquare
functionality--
let's see, I have
to do two jumps.
There we go--
for finding nearby venues.
So this is displaying them in
a list that allows you to
check in using Google Places
API, which you can find here.
Basically, its all of the sorts
of things that we were
talking about, all those best
practices around using passive
location provider, monitoring
location provider changes, and
being able to make sure that
you're doing everything in the
background in an intelligent way
that hopefully isn't going
to drain your battery.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now with TripIt,
the need for freshness is a
little more different.
The important thing
about TripIt is--
and let's bring up the giant
fake phone, shall we?
RETO MEIER: Oh, of course.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So with TripIt,
you're going to have--
you don't have any actual plans
in here, but I notice
that some of your friends do.
RETO MEIER: I was going to go
back to a trip that I did.
I think that's probably going
to be the easiest.
In fact, let me navigate
through that.
Let me go to past trips.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The idea with
TripIt is that it's all of
your travel information
in one place.
And it's going to show you the
most relevant thing first and
try and remove all the
irrelevant nonsense.
So it needs to know what time
it is, and it needs to know
where you are.
So in this particular case,
for instance, knowing that
we're going from Melbourne to
Perth is only important if we
are not in Perth.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And you
could find that in
two different ways.
You could find that out either
through location or by time.
But probably location is a
little safer because the
flight may have been delayed.
RETO MEIER: Or I may have
missed the flight.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
Same thing with the hotel, same
thing with everything.
The idea is, once you've got
there, you don't need to see
it anymore.
So it doesn't need to be updated
perhaps as frequently
as Foursquare does.
But it does need to update at
least in time to be able to
show and hide this
information.
RETO MEIER: And one of the other
things which I think is
really important is it needs
to be able to update--
there's sort of this balance.
Because if something does
change, if my flight time
changes or my hotel booking
changes, I need to see that
updated straightaway.
And that needs to be as low
latency as possible.
But the frequency of that
is pretty rare.
Once the travel is booked,
you're going to be lucky if
there's a change once
a day, if that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
You certainly don't want to be
checking every five minutes to
see if your flight's delayed.
Instead, what you really want
is to know exactly when your
flight's delayed and
then never worry
about it again, right?
So if I was doing this with just
my airline, my airline is
going to send me an SMS
to let me know that
the flight's delayed.
Now I don't want TripIt to send
me an SMS because there's
a better way to do
that, right?
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
You would want to--
yeah, exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In fact, I think
what we want is to--
hopefully what it
does is use GCM.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So let's have a look at some of
the things which you should
be able to do and
do really well.
So knowing where we
are is important.
But it's much more important
that I get my itinerary
changes as quickly
as possible.
And as I mentioned--
let me see if I can drop
this behind us.
It's neater.
Ah, that looks a bit weird.
Nonetheless, but this does
set up a conflict.
And like we said, it's that
idea of we want things to
happen straightaway, but we
don't want to have to do these
manual updates.
And so what that does
is that we--
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love these
graphs that you make.
Because they're complete
nonsense, but they do get the
idea across.
RETO MEIER: It goes up
and to the right,
up and to the right.
So it's a good graph.
Do the obvious graphs, people.
So again, it's this how do we
reduce the latency but not
have that increase
in battery life?
And that's genuinely what
happens, is that the fresher
the data is, the more
battery cost.
And where you actually want to
be is somewhere down here,
where you zero latency and
maximum battery life.
Interesting.
I think that was
my microphone.
You have to dance while
I fix this.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dance,
monkey, dance.
The reason I'm dancing instead
of sharing technical
information is because
I was sick yesterday.
So Reto had to script this
whole show himself.
And he's only been a little
bit bitter about it.
RETO MEIER: Only a little.
So even if you're not
downloading anything every
time you do the poll, you're
still potentially
draining the battery.
And that's because of the way
that the battery life cycle
model works-- or I should say
the cell network life cycle.
Or the cell radio, which is
going to say on high power for
around 10 seconds and around low
power for up to a minute
every time you ping a server.
Even if the server is
going, it's cool,
nothing you need to do.
It's still going to
drain the battery.
So if you're doing these updates
every minute, then
you're just leaving the cell
radio on permanently, which is
going to destroy your
battery life.
And so this is compounded by
the typical update rates of
apps like TripIt, where if my
itinerary changes, I want that
update, like, now, like
as soon as it happens.
But it's not going to
happen that often.
So how can we optimize
those updates and
minimize the latency?
Well, in fact--
and the most important
the answer is to use
Google Cloud Messaging.
Like, seriously, use Google
Cloud Messaging.
It is going to solve most
of these problems.
It's something which
TripIt, as far as I
can tell, has done.
Because there is that option to
choose manual slash push.
And I had a look in their
manifest, and they are using
those things.
But they still have the
options for those more
frequent updates.
So I want to hear from the guys
at TripIt and find out,
are you using it exclusively?
If not, why not?
And is there a reason for still
having that option to do
the manual polling, which
is just going
to drain the battery.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, there was
a time when Google Cloud
Messaging was C2DM, and
there was a cap.
You could only send so
many messages a day.
Now, that's not in
place anymore.
RETO MEIER: That's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So it may be
that in the past it was
difficult for them to guarantee
that they wouldn't
hit their C2DM limit.
RETO MEIER: That could
well be the case.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, of course,
Google Cloud Messaging isn't
doing anything magical.
It's just taking advantage of
the fact that a lot of apps
want to do this sort of thing.
So it makes a lot more sense to
coalesce that into one ping
that's done intelligently with
battery life in mind rather
than having everyone ping their
servers at whatever time
they feel like.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So it's a way that you can send
a message to a particular
device or set of devices used
by a particular user,
informing the app running on
that device that there's
updates which they
need to retrieve.
So the result is near-instant
updates with none of the
battery drain.
Or at least your app doesn't
get blamed for any of the
battery drain caused by--
which you would normally get
with regular poling.
So you get to blame it all on
Google, which is much cooler.
If anyone's going to get blamed
for battery drain, it
may as well be the system
rather than
your app, if you can.
So that's kind of
a no-brainer.
Similarly, you'll want
to pre-fetch as
much data as possible.
And it's particularly important
for an app like TripIt.
And it's something that they do
really well, in that I had
to think about whether or not
they did, which made me
realize that they must.
Because otherwise, I
would have thrown
it through a window.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: Offline access
here is absolutely vital.
For a lot of travel,
particularly when we were
jumping from country to country,
you don't have the
opportunity to buy a local SIM
just for the data, which you
often do if you're going to
be there for a week or so.
If you're going to spend 12
hours, you're just going to
have your core global roaming
SIM, and you're going to
disable data a lot.
Airports--
it often takes a long time once
you get out of flight
mode for the data connection
to start back up.
And I want to know where to
tell the taxi driver to go
without having to wait half an
hour for my phone to turn on
or to find Wi-Fi in order to be
able to get those updates.
So for apps like Foursquare,
though,
pre-fetching can be tricky.
Because there's no knowing which
places a user is going
to want to check into, or what
areas, what categories they're
going to want to explore.
And you can't pre-fetch
everything because that would
just be a huge battery drain
and a huge bandwidth drain,
particularly if you're
roaming.
So pre-fetching can be kind of
a cat and mouse game between
trying to get the right details
without wasting too
much bandwidth.
So for apps like TripIt, where
the information users want is
relatively small,
well-encapsulated around a
trip, and entirely
predictable--
you even know when they're
going traveling.
So you can wait to do the
pre-fetching until the day
before, pull it all down, stick
it on the device, and
then it's just there, and
it's just working.
So you can go into offline
airplane mode, and it all
still works.
So in that instance, I think
pre-fetching can be really,
really powerful.
On the same lines, it's really
important that you limit
bandwidth as much as possible.
And that means caching results,
particularly images,
or anything that's likely
to remain static.
Better still, your server should
specify the lifetime
and update time stamps
of its responses.
And that's what you can see in
this piece of code, which I'm
just going to step back from it
rather than go full screen.
So in this code snippet, we're
just checking the server
response headers to see if we
actually need to bother
downloading the rest
of response body.
So this is still going to cost
you in terms of hitting the
server to see whether there's
anything to get.
But at least you're not then
downloading extra data that
you already have or that hasn't
changed since the last
time you pinged the server.
IAN NI-LEWIS: If it's possible
to look ahead, too, and
determine how fresh each
piece of data is,
that's really useful.
Because in a lot of apps, I
would much rather know that a
piece of data is stale than to
not see it all and see a
loading bar or a progress
bar instead.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So it's probably also worth
mentioning that network state
and the type of network that
you're connected to you can
also be really important in
determining the frequency of
your data transfers and the
aggressiveness of your
pre-fetching.
So you can actually monitor
all of that.
As you can see in this code
snippet, where we're checking
the server response headers,
that doesn't seem true.
So in this snippet, what we're
doing is modifying the size of
the pre-fetching
cache depending
on the network speed.
So we're going to increase it
when we're on Wi-Fi or on 4G,
or we're going to drop it down
when we're on slower networks.
And so again, what we're doing
here is trying to find a
better balance between battery
drain and latency reduction.
I do go into much more detail on
this, on how to create apps
that are more efficient in my
I/O talk from earlier this
year, which is the link here.
It's bit.ly/protips2.
And there are more details on
creating efficient download
patterns in this Android
training class as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love that pro
tips picture, by the way.
Did JJ Abrams make
that for you?
RETO MEIER: He did, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, yeah.
I know a guy.
So finally, let's take a closer
look at Share Where,
which is our third app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's
Share Aware, of
course, not just Shareware.
It could be Shareware.
RETO MEIER: I think it's
just Share Where.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, it
is Share Where.
RETO MEIER: Because it's "where"
with, like, "where."
Homonyms for the win.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's Share,
Where, not shareware.
RETO MEIER: Not shareware.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: No.
Don't share this app.
That would be piracy.
And that would be bad.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wonderful.
RETO MEIER: Now unlike Fes--
unlike Fairsquare?
Unlike Foursquare and TripIt,
Share Where, which is what
I've written there, was
self-nominated and isn't yet
an editor's choice
on Google Play.
And so we're going to try and
be a little bit more--
IAN NI-LEWIS: We can
go nuts on this.
RETO MEIER: So we were going
to try and be a little more
constructive.
Let's say constructive.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There you go.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
Because you know, you put
your app up here.
I'm going to assume that you
want to have our feedback, or
you wouldn't have
asked for it.
But our goal is to still set
it up-- to bring it up to a
standard where we can show it
off to everyone else in our
pure Android collection.
So that's pretty much the goal
for any app that we look here.
We want to bring it up to
something which we can show
off to everyone else as a
great example of an app
IAN NI-LEWIS: Like you said
earlier in your morbid
preamble, this is an app that
has great functionality.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's something
that we really want to own,
but maybe not in this
exact form.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, exactly.
So we're going to give the
developer a chance to share
their experiences in
implementing some of our
suggestions and even explaining
some of the choices
that they've made in later
episodes of "Developers Strike
Back." So stay tuned for that.
But let's have a look
at the app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Let's do.
RETO MEIER: So thinking behind
this app is pretty
straightforward.
Let's just bring the
giant phone up.
So the idea here is that you're
going to create a bunch
of home screen widgets, which
all have predefined messages
which you can set to a
predefined audience.
So in case of emergency, or I've
just come home, I've just
landed, any of those things,
you can do it
all ahead of time.
Now, what happens when you load
the app up the first time
is you get this massive
screen of options.
Now, it is a widget app.
And there is a challenge
associated with widget apps in
that you can't just have the
main launcher icon launch the
app widget selector.
So you have to find a way to add
meaningful value in that
when you first open
up the app.
And that's a challenge that we
see a lot of widget apps do.
And so a lot of them will do
this, go straight into the
configuration screen, which
isn't a bad idea.
Except as you can see,
it's kind of a
complicated options menu.
There's a huge number
of options.
There's some information
in there as well
as some actual settings.
There's Help, About, Contact Us,
little tech fields which
just explain what
the app does.
It becomes a little bit
overwhelming for
a first-time user.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what it
feels like this needs more
than anything is a tutorial.
RETO MEIER: Sure, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It really does
need a little animated
tutorial with little
Back and Next
buttons and a Skip button.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, little
pictures of fingers
and things like that.
Because you need to help
people understand.
This is an incredibly useful
piece of functionality that a
lot of people are going to want,
especially people who
are not particularly
computer literate.
So they may or may
not know where to
find widgets in Android.
But they certainly
know how to--
they'll certainly know what
they want the app to do.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And they just need
to be told how to do it.
RETO MEIER: That's right.
And so what you can see on the
home screen here is the end
result of placing
these widgets.
So you can see that
we've got a--
we've got different-sized
widgets.
So this is a one by one.
And we've got a two by
one here as well.
If we click on--
IAN NI-LEWIS: So these aren't
resizable widgets?
RETO MEIER: They do have a
resizable one as well.
So there's a third option, which
I actually thought I'd
dropped on here, but maybe I
hadn't, which lets you do a
resizable one.
In fact, we can bring it
up on widgets here.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I just smelled
another business opportunity.
I could do home screen launcher
widgets like this and
go full metro.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So you can see here actually,
so this is the four by one,
which is actually resizable.
And you can see, again, this
is the configuration screen
for each of the widgets.
Now, straightaway, the
UI is a little--
it could use a little
work, let's say.
It looks kind of gingerbready.
It's got the black theme,
which I think in this
instance, doesn't really work.
Because you've kind of-- it just
feels like it's blending
into the background.
Because it is--
and it isn't full
screen either.
And I can kind of see why they
haven't gone full screen.
Because they want it
to look like it's a
configuration dialog.
But I think in this instance,
you could actually benefit
from actually launching a full
activity, which just, you go
into, you set things up, you hit
save, or OK, or whatever,
and your configuration
is complete.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And even if you
are going to do a full screen
or not full-screen dialog, it
should be prettier than this.
You know, part of this
is on us, right?
Orange on black was cool for
like five months back in 2010.
RETO MEIER: So it's claimed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's over.
Yeah.
RETO MEIER: We all
like blue now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: And you
can see, I mean--
IAN NI-LEWIS: We liked blue
before, actually, too.
RETO MEIER: That's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nobody
likes orange.
RETO MEIER: No one
You can see straightaway why
this kind of creates issues.
Straightaway, it looks
kind of weird.
And then if I click this-- so
they've done the right thing
here in that it does launch the
contact picker to let you
choose which contact you
want to include.
But this is all Holo themed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love how
Reto has two friends.
RETO MEIER: Well, this
is Daniel's phone.
One of Daniel's friends
is Daniel.
Awkward.
So you can get this cognitive
dissonance of like, well, I'm
definitely not in the
same app anymore.
So I don't know what's
going on here.
But if you click
through, then--
and again, you're bringing up
this kind of weird non-Holo,
non-modern UI.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's a really
strange mix of styles.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So you really want to try and
find a way to use the default
themes so that you're keeping
up with whatever style is
prevalent at the time on
whichever device it's installed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It also
feels like this just
could use more graphics.
It could use something that's
sort of explanatory, like--
I would even imagine maybe a
little view pager or something
that chooses different types of
widgets with graphics that
represent each of them.
RETO MEIER: The thing that
you're going to want to do.
Maybe even have a bunch
of presets.
That could be interesting.
There are certain use
cases which you've
probably got in mind.
And whether or not anyone will
ever actually use them, it
gives you that, like-- because
this is the first screen
you're going to see,
basically, when
you open this app.
If you know how widgets work,
you're not going to click the
launcher icon.
You're just going to go
Add Widget, drop your
two by one on there.
And this is the screen
you're going to get.
So this really needs to welcome
users, tell them what
the app does, how they're
supposed to use it, which
check box they're supposed to
have checked by default, and
make it as simple as possible.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I have
to reemphasize
what you just said.
Widgets should have presets, and
this one, in particular.
I mean, I think you'd cover 99%
of all possible cases for
this widget by just providing
five or 10 presets.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
From here, basically
everything works
as you would expect.
If you hit any of these
problems, it brings up a
confirmation dialog,
which you can skip.
So you can say, you know what?
If I want to send an emergency
message, I don't want to have
to do two clicks.
I just want to do one.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, and
once again, this
is a confusing dialogue.
I've just gone out of something
that's beautiful,
which is the Android home screen
with the very nice
widget, and now I'm looking
at this thing that--
it almost looks like, oops,
some pirated app just took
over my screen.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And so you want this to
be small as well.
We've got a whole bunch
of empty space here.
So if you're not going full
screen, go as small as you can
and make this-- it is just
a confirmation dialog.
I've already selected
all this stuff.
So you almost want to be able to
have a big Send button and
then maybe an ability to edit
as well if you want to.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
You want the Send button
to be big.
You want the information to be
there, but not editable.
Then you want to have
a way to go edit it.
Because by bringing up the edit
boxes as it is now, A,
you're introducing possible
error, where somebody
accidentally hits a key that
they didn't intend to.
And B, you're making it seem
like I have to edit it, like
that's my job now
is to edit this.
But no, I'm just trying to tell
Lassie where to dig to
get me out from underneath
the rubble.
RETO MEIER: Precisely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I don't
need all this.
RETO MEIER: And again, what
I really like here is this
ability to set a timer.
So you can say, set it five
minutes into the future.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That would be
great if they had used the new
control for that, though.
RETO MEIER: It kind of would.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's
intensely horrible.
RETO MEIER: It is.
And it's a really useful
function, so I would actually
want to have that as
the main thing.
So the two main things here are
I want send it now, send
in a few minutes, and
edit also, maybe.
So you almost want to flip the
importance of those things, so
that the editing functionality
is up on the top right, and
the being able to set a
timer is right there.
Also note that there's no way to
cancel here as well, which
is interesting.
So I'm done, but I
changed my mind.
Do I just want to send it now?
I kind of can't, which
is again--
it's just that user flow.
You want to make everything as
simple and easy as possible,
and make it impossible for
a user to do it wrong.
It's never the right answer
to say, oh, you're
using the app wrong.
That should never even
be an option.
They should only ever be
able to use it right.
One thing that they have done
nicely here is that one of the
recipients you can set is, share
with other app, which is
what we've got ticked now.
So if we do that, we can see
it's set up an ongoing
notification, which is--
time is set to an hour.
Interesting.
I'm going to cancel that
one and set off
another one really quickly.
Now, what it's going to do is
find my current location.
So now, all that information
we have it earlier on about
being able to find a location
really quickly
becomes really important.
Because I don't want to sit here
waiting for it to find my
GPS signal.
Anything is good enough
right now.
So you can by all means check
to see whether you can get
something really accurate.
If it doesn't happen within
5 seconds, screw it.
Go with what you had
last and send that.
Maybe send a second message.
Maybe make that an option.
So that's going to keep doing
its thing, retrieving current
location, for a while.
Interestingly, the app comes up
when that happens as well.
So I think you've probably done
something weird with your
intent receivers there.
So this shouldn't be getting
triggered from
clicking on the widget.
That's not a great
user experience.
So you want to make sure that
doesn't end up on the activity
stack associated with your
activity when you're entering
it from the widget.
So once that's happened, it
will actually then let you
send that message via any of the
other apps that you've got
on the system, which is a nice
way of doing things.
And in fact, I guess, maybe take
that as an opportunity to
talk a little bit about
exactly what
they're doing there.
Oh, there it is.
It's now got the location.
And we can share it using any of
the apps which are capable
of sharing text,
which is nice.
As we were saying, perhaps even
more so than Foursquare,
low-latency location detection
is absolutely
critical for this app.
So I'd be interested to know
from the developers what
techniques they're using to get
that quick and accurate
location fix, particularly
because it's not that quick.
So I'd like to see them doing
some work to improve that.
But one of the things they have
done well is this sharing
using any app dialog, which I
really like, and which is
something that TripIt has done
pretty well as well, making
use of intents to add more
functionality to their apps
without having to do
any extra work.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We're running
out of time.
But let's quickly go over what
you'd need to do to add the
sort of share intent
to your app.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Let's see.
So the details for what I'm
describing here are all on
this Android training class
on sharing content.
But the basics are actually
pretty straightforward.
You can create--
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, all that
typography looked right
on my laptop.
RETO MEIER: That's
they all say.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes, I know.
RETO MEIER: It was fine
on my machine.
So you create a new intent.
You set the action to send and
then populate the text extra
with the text you want
to transmit.
Then you just start an activity
using that intent.
Now, in this example here, I'm
actually forcing the activity
chooser to be displayed
every time.
That's because users will often
choose a default app for
handling a lot of content.
And for an app like this, you
actually want to give the user
a chance to say, well, which
specific thing do you want?
Because you've actually ticked
a box to say, send using
another app.
It kind of makes sense to give
them an opportunity to say
which app that they want.
So given that we are just about
out of time, I think
happily, we're just onto the
prescriptions for each of the
apps that we want to look at.
So let me pop all of this behind
us, and we'll bring
each of these up.
So I think this is the--
these are the prescriptions
for Foursquare.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
RETO MEIER: We didn't have a
lot because they've done a
pretty good job.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, they
really have, yeah.
RETO MEIER: I'm pretty
impressed.
I mean, the Foursquare team have
spent a lot time really
refining and honing their
app to try and make
it as good as possible.
They're really passionate about
creating a pure Android
experience, something that is
really user friendly, that
makes the phone work better,
that is always a positive and
not a negative, so
hats off to them.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
But as with any app that was
designed almost exclusively in
the Bay Area, it simply assumes
too much about your
network connection.
It needs to be better offline
and also better during
changing network conditions.
RETO MEIER: And so for me, I
guess the key thing-- and I
have brought this up with
the Foursquare team.
And I know they have good
reasons for not doing this,
but I'm going to mention it
anyway for anyone else who's
doing an app which does
something similar, is support
for being able to check
in when I'm offline.
So in the Bay Area, going inside
ends up having better
network access because everyone
has free Wi-Fi.
Not the case in London, and A
lot of the good venues are all
three stories underground so
that they don't get bombed in
the Second World War, but it
also means they have really
bad network coverage and no free
Wi-Fi, because nothing is
free in London.
So being able to check in, and
then just have all of that get
cached in a queue that then will
check me into all these
places once I do get network
access would be
a really nice feature.
So I'm going to take this
opportunity to ask the
Foursquare guys to do that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I would
love that.
RETO MEIER: Again.
TripIt--
we had a couple more suggestions
for them.
Again, this is an app
that we really love.
And this is one of those apps
which does everything right in
terms of the service
that it provides.
Absolutely love it, totally
indispensable, would use it
even if it was a terminal
prompt.
So that means that a lot of
what we're actually saying
here is-- in a way,
it's nit picky.
But it's also something which
can make the app that much
more appealing, that much
more fun to use.
And I think the key thing here
is it would be great to see
them take another pass at the
design, another pass at the
UI, now that we've had these
changes to Holo, so kind of a
UI overhaul would be kind
of nice to see.
So we've got all the
details there--
things like getting rid of the
menu button; not having to
click to load more lists, just
having that automatically fill
as we scroll; more use of
C2DM; better copying and
pasting; and overall
cleaner navigation.
And our third contender, the
Share Where location widget.
Again, I think the key here is
really a simplified workflow.
Everything should be easier,
particularly the first time.
It should just be click,
click, that's my wife's
contact, done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We have talked
about this many times, that a
lot of apps are just difficult
to get into.
And what you need do is just
figure out what the most
common use case is,
and Just fill that
stuff in for the user.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
It seems kind of
counterintuitive in a lot of
ways to say, we want you to
remove some of the options
from your app.
But it kind of works,
particularly for something
like this, which is really
focused, is figure out what is
it that people are downloading
this app to do.
And you can use analytics for
that to find out what are the
most common settings that
they're choosing?
What are the most common options
that they're clicking?
And make that not only the
default, but maybe the only
thing that you can do.
And then worry about expanding
those features in a way that's
consistent with the app usage
and easier to use
as time goes on.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And definitely
ditch the gingerbread.
We're sorry.
We're sorry we ever
put it out.
Go to Holo.
RETO MEIER: It happens.
But yeah, make a UI that's
consistent with the rest of
the framework, preferably
something that's Holo, but
definitely something which
doesn't feel like it's been
yanked out of an earlier
phone and stuck in the
middle of your app.
And that's, again, particularly
important for
anything which is
widget-based.
Because users aren't going
to be in your app much.
But when they are, you don't
want to make it feel jarring.
So that's kind of an
important step.
And also the widget, the widget
is what you're doing.
So make sure the widgets
are really beautiful.
They look kind of jaggy and
blurred on the Galaxy Nexus.
So make sure you've got the
right assets, nice scalable
assets, so that everything
looks really beautiful.
Because if it's going to live
on the home screen, it needs
to look nice.
People want their home
screens to look nice.
So I think that just about takes
us to the end of today's
"App Clinic." So two, both
Foursquare and TripIt of the
apps that we looked at, are
already featured in Google
Play's Editor's Choice category,
which makes them a
good chance to join the pure
Android collection,
particularly Foursquare, which,
having looked at again
today, just continues
to impress.
So wherever possible in the
future, we're going to
prioritize reviewing
apps by people who
self-nominated them.
So to be sure, please be sure
to head over to Trello to
nominate your apps.
And in fact I'll stick that
in the background as well.
I don't know if you
can read that.
I don't think that I can.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You might want
to bring that to the
foreground.
RETO MEIER: Why not?
Let's bring it to the front.
Boom.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes!
RETO MEIER: So that's
bit.ly/appclinictrello.
That's where you going to go
to nominate the categories
that you'd like us to review and
to nominate your apps in
particular for us to
take a look at.
So next week, what are we
looking at next week?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, if I knew,
I'd be a genius.
What are we looking
at next week, Dan?
RETO MEIER: I'm going to read
off the screen and say--
DAN: You guys are going
instant messenger.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, it's
on the screen.
RETO MEIER: I wouldn't have
asked you if I hadn't given
you the answer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, dear.
RETO MEIER: So we're going
to be choosing
that later this afternoon.
So if you have an instant
messaging app that you would
like us to check out, please
make sure that you've got it
nominated there so that we
can bring it up and talk
about it next week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
So, instant messaging, should
we narrow that down at all?
RETO MEIER: If you like.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So these
are apps like
Google Talk, or like--
I don't know.
Is AOL Instant Messenger
still a thing?
Or like Skype--
RETO MEIER: ICQ.
IAN NI-LEWIS: ICQ, yeah.
RETO MEIER: You're going
to go old school?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Sure.
So something that's going to
allow you to type and/or voice
to each other.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm particularly
interested in looking at what
they call the push-to-talk
apps.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely So
that'll be interesting one, an
interesting one to try and
demo the apps as well.
So we may need to get
someone in another
room to help us out.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
Oh, that will be interesting.
RETO MEIER: So that's it for
today's episode of "The App
Clinic." But be sure to tune in
next Tuesday for "Android
Design in Action" with Roman,
Nick, and Adam, live from our
New York studios.
Now, before we sign off, I do
want to ask our producer Dan
if we have any questions which
we should answer in the
negative 13 seconds
that we have?
DAN: I didn't see anything
that is worth your time.
We just have the normal
quality YouTube
comments going on.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Awesome.
DAN: Maybe better
luck next week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Keep
it up, haters.
RETO MEIER: So yeah, we would
love to answer any questions
you guys have during the show
about the apps or about any of
the technical content, or
indeed, just the structure of
the show, given that we're
trying things a little bit
differently.
So do be sure to send your
comments through on Google+,
in particular.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
If you happen to be looking at
this later on, remember, we've
got comments open on Google+
that you can take a look at.
And all you need do is mention
one of our names, and we'll
see it and look at it.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So we'll be back again next
week at the same time.
And in the meantime, we're going
to be taking a look at
some of our past "App Clinic"
patients to see if any of them
have attained the status
of pure Android.
So if you have had your app
reviewed and you've made some
changes and you'd love for us
to take a look at those
improvements, do let us know.
My name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: And thank
you for watching.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]